le croire
passé n'ont guère eu envie des revenus
leurs enfants leurs petits-enfants et
retourne plus volet vient y chercher une
trace ce qui fut pour les uns un lieu
des preuves et d'incertitude est devenu
pour les autres un lieu de leur mémoire
un des lieux autour duquel s'articule la
relation qui les unit à leur histoire
franz kafka l'amérique
lorsqu saison le jeune karl rossmann
entra dans le port de new york sur le
bateau déjà plus lent la statue de la
liberté qu'ils observaient depuis
longtemps lui apparut d'un sursaut de
lumière on nous dit que le braque
brandissaient les pcet élevé à l'instant
même et l'air libre souffler autour de
ce grand corps être migrants c'était
peut-être très précisément cela par une
épée là où le sculpteur a crû en toute
bonne foi mettre une lampe et ne pas
avoir complètement tort sur le socle de
la statue de la liberté
on a gravé les versets lèvres d'emma
lazarus donnez-moi ceux qui sont là ceux
qui sont pauvres au mas entassés
assoiffés d'air pur
les rebuts misérable de vaud terre
surpeuplée envoyez les moi c'est sans
patrie ballotté par la tempête
je lève la lande près de la porte d'or
de même les romances leader nationaliste
chinois huawei excepte l ait besoin
d'être réparé la voiture
le marché auteurs
champs-elysées n'était ouvert que jeudi
et le dimanche
il le savait mais il s'était dit qu'il
rencontrerait peut-être quelqu'un 9e
monsieur des oeuvres est qu'ils
regarderaient son carnet s'arrêterait
sur le plat ryobi ce trait sur la
victoire de samothrace apprécierez la
série des marianne ou le pétain
vermillon surchargé de la croix de
lorraine ligne avait personne même pas
un promeneur
les chaises de métal peinte en vert
alignée entre les arbres
en
il n'était même pas neuf heures du matin
r- était doux
narjisse municipal j'ai la nuit peer
champs elysées son plein désert
plus tard il referma le carnet et le met
dans la poche intérieure de sa veste
on
il sortit son cahier de texte
ce jour-là mercredi
il avait une heure aux français et une
heures de latin avec le cieux bong idiot
une lourde histoire avec monsieur
poirier une heure d'anglais avec
monsieur normand le pré midi une heure
de dessin avec monsieur jolie une heure
de sciences naturelles avec monsieur
léonard